[Musique]
c'est avec la voix de lady gaga que
débute la présidence de joe biden
[Musique]
ils sont
les chanteurs code brooks et jello ont
aussi offert des prestations durant la
cérémonie sur les marches du capitole
il y avait cette idée de représenter une
certaine diversité peut-être diversité
de genres avec lady gaga ses proches de
la communauté lgbt q le côté latino avec
jennifer lopez le côté country aussi le
média america avec avec gold brook
donc je pense que choisi des artistes
qui étaient les plus rassembleur
possible mais au milieu des stars de la
musique
si amanda gaulmyn une jeune poétesse dfl
12 ans qui ont volé la vedette en
récitant son poème de crise un vibrant
appel à l'unité écrit après l'assaut du
capitole un contraste avec l'entrée en
fonction du président entre hommes qui
avaient dû se contenter de vedettes de
second ordre
je pense qu'il y aurait à faire des
chèques faramineux à certains artistes
il y aurait pas réussi à les avoir
d'ailleurs le parti républicain depuis
quelques années en fait tu as tendance à
diaboliser hollywood et puis en fait
tout le milieu du divertissement
américain
on les voit comme toujours à la salle
des démocrates
on les dénonce comme des donneurs de
leçons le choix des invités souvent
chargé de symboles qu'il s'agisse d'un
buteur frei clown lors de la cérémonie
d'assermentation du président obama
[Musique]
ou de la cantatrice noirmain endersen en
1961 en pleine lutte pour les droits
civiques
lors de l'investiture du président john
f kennedy une journée souvent placée
sous le signe de l'unité de l'inclusion
comme lorsque le président reagan invite
jessye norman en 1985 au delà de la
cérémonie au capitole il ya généralement
de grands rassemblements et des balles
ou quatre coins de washington
mais cette année pandémie oblige la fin
sera télévisuelle avec celebrity
américain une grande émission animée par
tom hanks et attendent d'être démis le
bateau justin timberlake jon bon jovi ou
encore bruce springsteen dix inédits
alexandre charti radio canada montréal
[Musique]
et
à
m